hi Bo Bachman on the vice president of
Galpin motors and president of Galvan
Auto Sports we start over
hey I'm trying to show over here my very
first car was in 1965 Mercedes 220 se
that my grandmother willed make it was a
first car I ever customized owned and
it's the last material possession I
would ever sell in life I'm one of the
lucky guys that still has her first car
my dream car when I was a kid it was
actually a goal wagon and I just thought
it was gorgeous
it looked fast and I loved the way the
doors opened on that car and still today
I lust after that one
probably my favorite cars are 1965 GT
350 now that Shelby literally was in
someone's garage since the early 1970s
so it sat there for 40 years it actually
was sold brand-new at Galpin Ford and it
is in the exact same shape as when it
came out of that garage and I think it's
just perfect the way that it is I mean
the worst cars of Pontiac Aztek I mean I
can't
it's that's still it they won't most
Awkward design I think of all time I
mean I don't even understand how that
car ever got made I don't understand why
anyone would drive it I don't understand
I'm a lucky guy I get to drive a lot of
different cars so today I'm driving a
Jag and tomorrow I might drive a Mustang
and unfortunately then I got to take my
kids to school on a Honda minivan and
then I can drive something fun again
occasionally an Aston Martin so I'm
lucky because I get to switch cars a lot
I know this is gonna sound weird but the
one car I've always wanted to drive was
a 1939 Peugeot knee and Falaschi bodied
talbo logo it was one of those striking
cars I've ever seen in my life I saw
when I was a kid and I always thought
who if I could just ride that car and I
still have that fantasy today thank you
for visiting the Galpin collection and
please subscribe to GQ calm for even
more great videos subscribe to GQ calm
and don't forget let us know what you
want to see on car collectors